[Music]
this week we've got Netflix weed forced
splits and a hotel intruder tight
take it away Tiffany check out whatever
day
mmm-hmm so for our first story Netflix
was selling their own branded weed yeah
I've heard they are going bankrupt
that's why I'm they trying to make some
money are they like no money how they're
spending a lot on shows there have you
seen the content they put out recently
they just been buying everything shitty
content like this particular so the
reason why I started selling weed is to
promote their newest show called
disjointed oh yeah no it's because when
you're high you just want to sit and
keep watching more shows 1 2 % well also
they didn't it's cuz they did the Ashton
Kutcher show the farm and they're like
[ __ ] we lost our what is that show up
well I'll tell you what it's about it's
a tax write-off for Netflix that's all
it is that's that's like half of the the
donut shops in LA I'm like this is a
front for drugs for Netflix like half of
their cartoon shows are just like that's
where they just throw cash at to like
burn cash with the IRS it's just tax
write-offs City I heard that's what
happened with ridiculous 6 we try to
watch that out of salad hall of like
dude what don't balance this is
destroyed my childhood right now it's
called a write down my friend that's all
it is there's no way it's any breakdown
yeah protect so right off no write down
write it down yeah honey I know trust me
I'm a man I know these things you know
Adam Sandler made more money with his
Netflix deal than he ever did in his
whole entire career what doing movies
he's not right yeah well that's why he
had to do like a huge like or they body
show all of his movies he's like Plus
isn't his new his new bunch of movies
does that include his 3d blu-ray money
who the [ __ ] is buying that [ __ ] juice
same [ __ ] I'm like who's buying this
[ __ ] what is this yeah but this weed
here they came out with 12 different
streams it's Netflix we it is so all
three of these Netflix and chill but for
reals like really chill like really
really tail so they were they actually
partnered up with the dispensary here in
LA in West Hollywood and they were only
selling it for a one weekend and in that
one weekend they sold about more than a
pound of the entire weed so yeah that's
really enough I used to sell drugs and
that's not that much if you're a big
corporation well they said that they
sold over a hundred jars which equals
roughly a pound Oh from that location
well that there was only well they
didn't really publicize it wasn't
technically Netflix themselves like they
didn't keep any of the profits I mean it
was just that they partnered up just to
kind of promote the show because this is
what I was thinking
Netflix has millions of but smoking
customers right that [ __ ] the pound and
once it goes for sale it should have be
gone within the first second it should
have be gone before it was even on sale
yeah I thought it was like they were
sending you some weed with you order the
dvds cuz like everyone switched over to
streaming so it's like well if you get
the DVD you also get some weak mail
order we'd would be so lucrative
yeah like never having to leave and
never having to deal with like shitty
creepy drug deal well apparently they
already have like services in certain
cities that already have weed where they
actually had like an uber for we yeah we
like a post mate yeah I go pose make one
uber but do all this [ __ ] is because a
weed by the way like Netflix you don't
have to leave your house to go get moves
in yeah like what is all this door -
[ __ ] and like rub huh like you don't
have to leave your house you can smoke
weed at home and have food delivered to
your door like that's that's what's the
next thing that's where that's where you
should put your money dating comes to
your door pretty good man
that's pretty good that's like rape yeah
oh yes so here are the strains here
these all three of these have been
inspired by disjointed and then the
other ones they're inspired by other
Netflix original series look like
handles like that Beth and really beyond
like I like the bamboo on the top yeah
they make it they make a female friendly
so the reason why they're inspired by
these shows is that it's the highest
that supposedly gives you is similar to
the experience you get when you watch
the show the vibe of the show reel who
say right I I swear every one that
smokes weed is like a scientist they're
always like this dream will do this to
your bodies like this with this
ridiculous 6ku so make you want to kill
yourself don't do that one don't do that
yeah don't can I ask why do this pickle
is sick squish I do I do I do this
challenge with my brothers and to my
friends in town where I call it the
batman robin challenge and i have people
sit try to sit through the movie Batman
and Robin with George Clooney and and
when they tap out is when is when like
they have failed the challenge and I
think we should all do that with some of
this [ __ ] like these Adam Sandler yes
the ridiculous exchange i watch the
what's it called sandy Wexler was
[ __ ] did you get through the whole
thing you should watch ridiculous
conceptually it was it could have been
great you know I mean I think like what
they were doing with it but it was a
trash movie and then ridiculous 6 I
watched about halfway through you would
have waited you're a [ __ ] man among
man my friend we couldn't get there in
10 minutes
I got through barely 10 minutes the one
the only one that I thought was decent
was the one that he didn't bet was a
David Spade do-over yeah
I wasn't really gonna hit whoever was
decent I was like I didn't feel I was
like yeah I'd give it like a five you
know I mean that's not bad
what's out of what yeah it was one of
those movies where it's like oh yeah
it's a basic comedy movie that's okay
it's okay but I like the premise for it
I was like at least like the premises
yeah I'm not LaBrie I keep reading
that's an Adam Sandler movie because it
didn't look like trash when I saw like
it like went after watch the chill I
didn't feel like I needed to take a
shower like three times you know but the
good news on Adam Sandler being that
terrible is that no matter what y'all's
movie can't be that bad
I hope well I know that after that I
watched water boy and that [ __ ] was
hilarious II you know it's telling you
watch one of his old stuff
the magic is different like when you
watch one of his old I think he gives a
[ __ ] it's a it's like no he can't do to
ruin kids and then he started making
concepts like kids it's like what's his
face so what's his name
Thandi good nights Will Ferrell Will
Ferrell right because he just has like
those [ __ ] bucket list shits where
he's in a lifetime of its special dude
that she was hilarious though it wasn't
supposed to be funny
no I think he was he knows him and
Kristen Wiig yeah but see that was a
thing too cuz like he put it out you
know they were asking him why are you
doing he goes I just have a bucket list
thing and he took he mentioned that yeah
yeah and he said was supposed to be
funny but it's funny just because it's
crystal it would I love that that shit's
yeah sort of like how James Franco was
on like Days of Our Lives or some [ __ ]
I'm like good for you man that's
hilarious like it's just funny as [ __ ]
he made that terrible [ __ ] Mexican
movie where he was just it's like almost
like slightly offensive that was that
was one cassadee me Padre that was a
really [ __ ] funny was that his like
macho Libre no he said he just wanted to
do a movie in all Spanish okay that
movie's absurd - there's like a talking
white tiger and [ __ ]
yeah so he doesn't give that's what
happens when artists don't do fanservice
anymore can they just do whatever the
[ __ ] they want it could come out with
trash yeah
sometimes it's better to just follow
what your manager tells you to do that's
a dark reality I don't want to be in
that world
all right next story now is this viral
video of this cheerleader being forced
to do splits and the coach responsible
for all this I saw this video and I'm
just gonna say that I had the same thing
done to me when I was in tech one though
as a Asian kid it's not that big of a
deal let's see the video what is it you
know they're just tearing the relays
apart we'll just put you're down by the
shoulders oh here we go
is she hurting like tighty-whities or
something there you go oh my god the way
you lifted it was like you should have
slowly lifted her the coach that has now
been fired why don't they do that in
gymnastics and all kinds of sports you
know though I will say this well and
when we was done - I assume because we
detect one though yeah like I detect one
though as well they pushed you down by
the shoulders yeah and it's just sort of
like you know they do helping you down
kind of it wasn't really like a like
they're holding her legs they're
actually pulling
they had this thing though or they used
to have your partner go so you do like
this the wide leg stance and then your
other partner puts his legs on your
ankles and he kicks it out as far as
possible yeah so I would scream too but
the splits not anymore
yeah you're pretty flexible though good
you you're still really flexible
yeah for my so I still have like what is
because of [ __ ] like that though it's
because someone ripped it apart yeah
when I saw that [ __ ] on that Jean Claude
Ben see they don't make movies like that
anymore remember
oh what's the call was it bloodsport no
kickboxer yeah they had the ropes and
they [ __ ] rip yeah but like when do
you use that in life the splits
I mean jean-claude Van Damme doesn't
every movie yeah even doesn't with two
semi-trucks that's right he does any
commercials today just for no reason
actually it's made of millions of
dollars yeah he worth every penny of
stretching class so we the only person
that that paid off
okay well that's somebody paid off so
there you go sometimes you need to cool
your nutsack you guys spread those legs
but I we have no getting pushed down
just like we do the trucks is it yeah
the truck things to New Guinea push down
gently is different than like what that
was which is like they're stretching it
was pretty distressing her for rape or
whatever it is well that's what it
seemed like it was like the way to react
is insane and she wasn't the only
student either because apparently a
police station got several videos of
other students that anonymously to them
because they were saying that she's
anonymous they're saying that the school
had been notified of these videos back
in June because these were taken during
their cheerleading summer camp and then
apparently the school didn't do anything
about it and then that's why whoever
sent these videos sent them to the
police because they wanted something to
be done and then finally that's one step
four taken to finally have an
investigation into this to see what's
going on video this or was it the coach
was the coach like I want a video this
to show you how silly you're being yeah
and then later on he's like he's like
hey he's like at the police station he's
like play the tape he's like you'll see
Hey look look see see she's crying on
chef Roy this is defense I want to see
the court like the court tape right like
stupids there it's a save tape he's like
your honor
I got y'all tell you what my defense
attorney as I swore it off I said I
don't need a defense attorney play the
tape yeah just watch just watch I rest
my case
I've been the judge what the [ __ ] is
going on ya know there were even five
other school employees that have been
placed on a leave like pending this
whole but the real question is do they
when do they win medals like is this
team yeah are the is this team like
elite no this coach had just recently
started at this school he doesn't know
what he's doing
no because he has other schools for the
same [ __ ] this all the guy does is just
cheerleaders like he doesn't do teach it
any classes or anything so he's like I
gotta whip these cheerleaders in the
shape these cheerleaders are [ __ ] oh
my god that was like the same training
regimen that they used the bad guys used
in the Mighty Ducks you remember like
the same kind of [ __ ] so he you know
he's just watching this kind of [ __ ]
he's like he's like yeah you have to be
tough with the children to make the
children do what you want with all these
articles every time something like this
happens there's always like this side
comment where it says he's been fired
multiple times for this before [ __ ]
hired this I'll tell you who somebody
who uses the Opera browser they don't
use Google Chrome they use that shitty
ass hold on let's Google this man real
quick looks totally fine to me brothers
yeah who says that [ __ ] every exactly
let's opera this thing yeah can't find
anything this is MySpace page yeah
exactly
- he was late to anyone yeah damn I
think if I was her dad I would tell the
cheerleaders yeah good job and I'll I'll
tell her like oh no they did what that's
[ __ ] up but can you do the splits no
the real question yeah if she could do
the splits now that is the question
she's probably really damaged she's
young dumb probably has like pulled
muscles she can't walk like and
emotionally damaged that's okay she
could heal faster than us I hope you
bought up picking up on the sarcasm
because if not I'm really not me no dude
that's my whole problem is nobody knows
and beats okay yeah
yeah sometimes you're really like
convincing your drive oh thank you
the drive is there yeah all right for
our last story there is this man in
Florida that snuck into a hotel and
racked up a 2180 dollar bill without
ever checking into the room
why well somebody else would've missed
yeah so he actually snuck in right after
the guests had checked out and he
claimed to be to be with those guests
and so hotel staff never questioned him
he kept ordering room service and spa
treatments oh my god that's genius
pretty good but then finally the staff
called police and they were like hey
there's this man here's here that's just
racking up this bill he doesn't plan on
paying it how do you stick it I was
wondering the same thing does you have
to have a key and stuff I don't know and
then like how do you know when people
are checking out and all that cuz I take
over there yeah just calling like oh
actually I'm gonna stay for another week
you know like how do you even know he
was able to sneak in somehow like
through a window or something or like
through a balcony and sometimes people
just leave their keys in the hotel
Wickliffe they check out because you
don't really need to like I do they
facially check out all the time yeah so
then if he got in there like through
balcony and then like they left the key
I mean it's their fault yeah they don't
really mention exactly how he got in cuz
I was curious too I'm like how do you
speak in how do you know I had the same
question cuz you can't go you can't do
it at the Luxor it's a pyramid Motel
before me I'm just thinking like okay
how do you rack up $2,100 like what are
you order three sandwiches like [ __ ]
hotel food so absurdly expensive dude
spa treatment oh my god he was there for
three days three days 2 grands who
grabbed those spa treatments are like a
couple hundred bucks anyway yeah they
yeah spas treatments and there's like
that other part of the page where I
don't even read cuz too expensive super
window really I said the first page is
too expensive no apparently this isn't
the first time we did it either he had
done it how did they catch that like
obviously he's not using his real name
like how do they know oh this is the
hotel of spa master that we've been
looking for you know like healthy yet
other hotel cards on his on his person
when they when they finally arrested him
and then he said that the reason why he
did it was because he went to Atlanta
and he went to some party and he was
drinking there like he went through a
drug binge with like Hulu surgeons and
like he didn't feel like himself so then
he and he just decided to sneak into
that hotel well there's a very specific
drug that makes you do that so he
traveled all the way to Florida I know I
would she's like I just needed this body
yeah you know I mean that's better
he's lazy if you think about it he has
all this time to go to different hotels
wait for people to check out and then
sneak in that room and then hang out
there like he has no job
he just chills at hotels that's kind of
tight it sounded pretty good it is kind
of cool it sounded pretty good to me
yeah I'm just jealous South Carolina and
he's going cross-country to like he's
going from the other ones that he had
done and he had smoking too that was in
Florence oh okay this one's in the south
what's the South Carolina ain't no
offense if you live there or something
I've been to North Carolina they had
really good fried chicken called
Bojangles and yeah and there's a law
called the
I think but if you serve regular tea by
law you have to have sweet tea there
that's really it's an old law that they
just never change people in the South
love their sugar man let you get the
sweet tea
oh I drink it I'm like god damn and I
see somebody next to me they're putting
more sugar into it I seen that too yeah
Oh God
everyone I knew from the South they all
had closets full of Mountain Dew too man
just filled with Mountain Dew yeah and
then they would they would run out of
the case in Mountain Dew and they would
go get another Mountain Dew at the
grocery store to replenish their stock
like oh my god yeah it's like I remember
when I was a waitress and someone
ordered sweet tea there's a lot of
people that would order sweet tea and
like I had no idea what that was because
I've grew up here those we have tea and
sugar and sweetener
we've sweetened iced tea but it's not
the same it's like yeah it's not the
same
and then McDonald's came out with sweet
tea and I was like oh make some really
important yeah yeah there's no good
sweet tea in California not even really
yours actually honey
this earth to put me down that's what
girls are for dudes like it's like you
know what a guy tells a story and then
the girlfriend has to destroy that yeah
it's not true yeah like with my friends
[ __ ] you lost in that fight you're
asking like 180 really dude did you
really honey I don't think so
she's like why can you complain when
you're taking the groceries upstairs I
know [ __ ] sometimes I off handle they
do that like I'm like you know how
you're really bad at packing the car
trunk yeah I think the stuff were proud
about too crazy man she tells me I can't
pack the trunk
you can't I'm like I'm gonna pack the
trunk better than it you like the wobbly
packs ever that's exactly what I did on
everything I'm like guys are supposed to
be good
he's not good and we're not packing a
lot of [ __ ] we're just taking like a
weekend trip so does it matter the way
you put things in the trunk is like nuts
is like not in line like it's a cup but
you're the organized girl though
so the other night he's like hey Kent
can you come with me to the park and I'm
like well [ __ ] it's not I'm 10 o'clock
at night it's like 9:45 like why every
one of the park and she's like I have to
get up I have to go get around that's
not how I said it she said no she did
she got quiet in our own home no I was
like I need you to come with me a park
yeah there's a bunch of weirdoes there
picket to the park and I'm like I'm
collecting sand for my moon ritual was
eclipse yes yeah but also because it was
a new moon on the day of the Eclipse so
she then takes it home you know don't
you she didn't like that's the weirdest
part she then takes it home and takes a
[ __ ] bath with the rock it's it I
cleaned it first and so now when we have
kids and they're like well dad can I go
to the park like and I'm like no it's
like [ __ ] 10 o'clock at night and
there's weird people who go to the park
looking for let me tell you this is like
it's a new subscription box that I just
got it was the first time I ever got it
and like I so I was excited to try it
and then I thought cuz during the New
Moon they could send you a new moon
ritual and a full moon ritual and it's
just like a candle and like a bath salt
or whatever and you're like think about
your intentions for the new cycle and
you take a bath well for the full moon
or for the new moon cycle you
do like get a jar of soil put your
intentions in a soil and also find a
rock from the outside that you bless
with sage and then you meditate it with
it in the best is the most like
millennial shape I know that it was
gonna be so intrusive I just thought it
was gonna be like the first one that was
like light a candle and meditate but I
bought this moon box I gotta do it now
gotta go get the rock from the outside I
know people who have believed in that
moonstone [ __ ] for the longest time you
know to each their own
however stupid it is this girl she
charts her moon stones for under the
mint or brain power for her SATs right
that [ __ ] got like a you had the moon
on her side oh yeah no but then she they
always blame the moon yeah no no I did
it wrong I'm gonna say that actually if
it's a girl the moon actually messes
with your emotions and stuff and having
a moon stones she did it also putting
aside her [ __ ] and then yeah I'd like
that
what is it Gwyneth Paltrow [ __ ] oh what
a [ __ ] / leg in your [ __ ]
what is that [ __ ] glitter ya [ __ ]
glitter it's like your [ __ ] deserves
some relaxation or something something
like that that's fun I think Witter just
pieces of glass I'll not put that in my
purse a plastic this nasty I hope you
guys enjoy this video for more please
subscribe to our Channel and you can
check out the last video right here
[Music]